Okay. Good afternoon.
Welcome to the Clinical Trials Mini
Symposia. You are at the Aiming for a Cure,
Perioperative Clinical Trials. We are your co-chairs.
My name is Alice Ho. I'm from Houston Methodist Academic
Institute. Dr. Tanabe?
I'm Ken Tanabe. I'm from Harvard Medical School and Mass General Brigham.
So we have a very exciting and diverse
line of abstracts to be presented today.
They cover a very wide range of tumor types,
and they're all in this very exciting setting,
perioperative, the neoadjuvant, and I think that presents
very unique windows of opportunity to assess
biomarkers and response. And so, I think it's a wonderful
theme to chair a session on. We also have
a very diverse and talented group of speakers, which we welcome
hosting. And
one thing I'd like to remind you all before we start is that there is
this QR code that is visible to you, and if
you
click on the link after you scan it, that's a place where you can enter
questions. Another way of asking questions is simply coming to the
mic, and time permitting, there's five minutes allotted after
each presentation. If it goes on time, we would love to hear your questions.
So thank you very much.
And with that, I'd like to welcome the very
first speaker,
Dr. Foote from Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer Center.
We cannot see it.
Yeah, I can't see it. I can't see the...
Okay.
That's better.
Hello, everyone. Thank you so much for joining us. My name is Mike Foote.
I'm a medical oncologist at Memorial Sloan Kettering in GI Oncology, and
I'm thrilled to show you the interim results of our Phase 2 trial of
neoadjuvant trastuzumab tucatinib combined with chemotherapy
in locally advanced rectal carcinoma.
These are my disclosures.
Locally advanced rectal cancer is conventionally treated with tri-modality
therapy, which consists of chemotherapy, chemoradiation, and
surgery. This can be given in several different ways.
When the chemotherapy and the chemoradiation are given before surgery, we term
this total neoadjuvant therapy. Other centers may give the chemotherapy after
surgery.
Radiation and surgery have a lot of side effects.
Over a third of patients with rectal cancer require a total mesenteric excision
of their tumor, which is a very morbid procedure that necessitates a
permanent ostomy bag. It's a life-changing experience.
Radiation can cause permanent bowel, bladder, infertility, and sexual
dysfunction in that region.
Because of the side effect profile, many people around the world are trying
to evaluate tumors after they receive total neoadjuvant therapy with
chemotherapy and chemoradiation to see if the tumor still remains on
endoscopy and on scans. If the tumor is absent on these
assessments, then we term this a clinical complete response, and these patients
can be safely managed without surgery.
However, the majority of patients have residual disease even after these treatments
and require the morbid surgery.
We asked ourselves, looking at the landscape of targetable alterations in
metastatic colorectal cancer, if targeting some of these alterations
upfront in early disease could help improve clinical complete response
rates to avoid surgery.
We focused specifically on HER2-amplified tumors.
HER2 amplification is a relatively rare event in metastatic colorectal
cancer of about 4% of patients, but the prevalence in early-stage
disease is not well known.
Patients with HER2-amplified metastatic colorectal cancer that had
progressed on standard chemotherapy treatments were treated with trastuzumab and
tucatinib in this Phase 2 trial, and the results were very
impressive. You can see here deep and durable responses for these patients,
even after these tumors had progressed on chemotherapy.
Notably, RAS mutations confer resistance to this treatment, so patients with
KRAS-mutated tumors were not included on the study.
Based on this exciting data, we saw a strong rationale for including these
treatments upfront in patients with early-stage rectal cancer.
Most HER2-amplified tumors are left-sided, so we thought there might be a
concentration of HER2 amplification in these cancers.
For patients that are symptomatic and need to go on treatment quickly, HER2
amplification is very easy to test for with immunohistochemistry, FISH,
and/or DNA sequencing. In breast cancer, HER2-targeted treatments are
standard of care, and they've been very successful in the neoadjuvant setting.
Notably in breast cancer, patients are treated for a pretty long time, a year or
so, including before and after surgery.
And finally, the data I just showed you was very impressive using trastuzumab and
tucatinib in advanced metastatic disease that was HER2 amplified.
So we asked ourselves, can neoadjuvant therapy with HER2 blockade increase
the complete clinical response rates of locally advanced rectal cancer?
And we evaluated this question in a number of settings.
First, we had an introductory period of HER2 treatment alone for six weeks.
We then added chemotherapy to this treatment to have an overall 21 weeks,
about five months of total medical treatment for these cancers, and this was the
main assessment. And finally, we asked this question in patients that also
needed radiation after the completion of this therapy.
This is the study schema. We enrolled patients that had locally advanced rectal
adenocarcinoma that were HER2 amplified and KRAS wild type.
All patients were mismatch repair proficient.
We first gave them six weeks of trastuzumab and tucatinib, which target HER2 by
itself, and then we had an exploratory assessment.
And then finally, we added chemotherapy to this treatment to complete, again, about
five months of total medical therapy.At week 21, patients were
assessed with endoscopy, biopsy, CT scan, and rectal MRI to
evaluate for the presence or absence of tumor tissue.
If the tumor was absent on all these assessments, the patients were deemed to have
a complete clinical response, which was the main endpoint of our
study. If the patient had a complete clinical
response, they were given the option for surveillance without radiation or
surgery. If patients had residual disease, they were treated with
standard chemoradiation or surgery.
We hypothesized that addition of HER2 treatment in the early-stage setting would
increase the complete response rate from the conventional 20%
expected with chemotherapy alone up to 40%.
To evaluate this hypothesis, we employed a Fleming two-stage design.
In the first stage, 17 patients would accrue.
If less than four patients had a complete clinical response, the study would end
early for futility. If eight or more patients had a complete clinical response,
the study would end for success. If between this number had a complete clinical
response, we would enroll another 21 patients for stage two.
Patients were assessed for HER2 amplification with standard methods,
including immunohistochemistry.
If patients had 3+ immunohistochemistry, they were allowed on the study.
You can see an example here. If patients had 2+ staining and an
elevated FISH ratio, they were also allowed to enroll in the study.
And finally, we assessed for KRAS wild-type status using genomic sequencing.
Again, all patients were KRAS wild type.
We employed an institution-wide screening protocol for all patients with
early-stage rectal cancer, which had really never been done before.
We screened about 459 patients. Out of those patients, 11
patients or about 2.4%, had HER2 amplification.
We enrolled 10 of these patients in the study.
You can see them here now as of our last data cutoff.
Notably, this is a high-risk population.
Seventy percent of the patients had clinical lymph node-positive disease, clinical
stage three disease, and these were big tumors that were close to the sphincter.
So a lot of these patients, the majority of them would have required a large
rectal surgery on their tumor.
Finally,
70% of the patients had 3+ HER2 IHC.
Of those 10 patients, nine of them completed the first six weeks of
trastuzumab and tucatinib therapy alone. You can see them here on this slide.
And we saw a very impressive overall response rate of about 78%
with disease stability in the other two patients.
This is much higher than expected.
After the full course of medical therapy, including HER2 treatment plus
chemotherapy, we had eight patients complete this as of the data cutoff,
and half of the patients or 50% had a complete clinical response.
I want to also note that no patient progressed on this treatment during this
introductory period. No patient missed an opportunity later to get
radiation or surgery because we extended this window.
We evaluated the characteristics of patients that had a complete clinical response
versus those that did not. The TNN staging was very similar between
the two groups, but you'll note that the HER2 immunohistochemistry results were
strikingly different. All the patients who had a complete clinical response had
HER2 3+ staining, whereas only one patient without a clinical complete
response had HER2 3+. And notably, this patient had a complete response
after radiation was given to their treatment.
We also evaluated the DNA quantity of HER2 using copy number
analysis and found that this may be a more robust biomarker of patients that get a
clinical complete response.
Ninety percent of the patients had a grade one or two adverse event, but these were
very manageable, and no patient had to discontinue treatment from it.
Grade three events are highlighted here.
The majority of them were transient liver enzyme increases that were reversible.
No patient had a grade four or grade five adverse event.
After the conclusion of their therapy, patients were closely monitored to
evaluate for recurrence.
Notably, four patients in our study did have recurrence after their initial period
of complete
medical therapy. Three of the patients had a complete clinical
response and recurred within a median of four months.
Now, just to take you through it, the first patient actually stopped their therapy
early because they had a very early complete clinical response, so they didn't
complete their full treatment. The second patient actually was lost to follow-up
about halfway through, so he also did not complete his full treatment.
This is for socioeconomic reasons.
All of the patients had positive HER2 staining on the recurrent tumors.
So there's a thought that maybe these patients just needed more time, akin to
breast cancer.
All recurrences were salvageable without surgery, and as of about two and a half
years of median follow-up, 63% of patients have avoided surgery
and have rectal preservation. We evaluated
correlatives as well to see which tests might help predict
for clinical response as well as track patient outcomes.
We evaluated circulating tumor DNA, which was taken every six weeks for patients
on the study.
Overall, this was a great biomarker for tracking response and recurrence.
You can see that patient two we talked about had a deep response to HER2 therapy
but was lost to follow-up about halfway through the disease course and never
cleared their ctDNA. Patient three had almost a near
CR after medical therapy. You can see the ctDNA is still present but didn't
go to nothing until after radiation was added, and they had a complete response.
And finally, the last patient had a complete clinical response to medical therapy
but later recurred. And you can see the ctDNA also spikes.
We also evaluated an experimental PET MRI scan that used an 89
zirconium trastuzumab tracer, which we hypothesized was specific for
HER2-amplified tumor tissue.
The first row, you see the patient at baseline had a highly avid tumor on their
baseline scan, and you can see a big tumor on their endoscopy.
And after they had a complete clinical response, you see the absence of avidity and
resolution of the tumor.
So the key take-home messages of this study so far, which is with early
results, is that HER2 blockade was very active and provoked
responses that were higher than we expected in
HER2-amplified locally advanced rectal cancer.
The response rate to this early introductory period of trastuzumab and tucatinib
was 78%. Half of patients had a complete clinical response to
neoadjuvant trastuzumab, tucatinib, and chemo.And
63% of patients had a complete clinical response to trastuzumab,
ducatinib, chemo, and chemoradiation.
We saw strikingly that patients with 3+ HER2 IHC amplification
predicted for their complete response, but we also have a continuous variable,
which is the copy number of the DNA, which may be a more robust biomarker for a
response.
Notably, three patients who had a complete response recurred locally, but all these
patients, as of the data cutoff, have been salvaged without surgery.
Sixty-three percent of patients overall, after about two and a half years, have
been managed non-operatively, and that's median follow-up.
And we think that based on the recurrent tissue having HER2 positivity, that it may
still be sensitive to treatment. So we may just need more time.
Enrollment continues on our study.
We've achieved the stage one endpoint.
We'd like to thank all of the collaborators, patients, and sponsors for this
study. I'd like to also especially thank Dr.
Andrea Cercek for her leadership of the trial, as well as Dr.
Luis Diaz, and I'm very excited to answer your questions and have a nice
discussion. Thank you so much.
Okay, questions for Dr. Foote.
Oh, sure. Yeah, sorry, I'll stay up there.
I see someone at the microphone over there.
Hi. That's nice talk. Thank you. I may have missed this,
but how many of the screened patients had the
requisite HER2 threshold
but were excluded because they had concomitant KRAS
mutations?
That's a great question. I had it as an asterisk, and I didn't draw attention to
it. So no patient actually had a KRAS mutation. Isn't that interesting?
So all of the early-stage rectal tumors that were HER2 amplified did not have a
KRAS or NRAS mutation.
Okay.
So no patient was excluded for that.
I'm asking it the other way around.
How many patients with KRAS mutations had HER2 amplification?
How many patients with KRAS mutations have HER2?
Yeah.
So if they didn't have HER2, we didn't
evaluate them further for the study, so we didn't do KRAS screening on every
patient. We screened 450-some patients for HER2 only.
To do the KRAS at the same-- We did KRAS as a second step, so we don't know the
KRAS status of all the patients, but it's an interesting question.
So finally, do you think this is generalizable to other targetable, which you
showed that pie diagram, there was a bunch of other potential targetable
strategies. Do you think this is generalizable?
I think it's a very interesting question. I think it certainly could be applied.
I mean, HER2-targeted treatments in advanced metastatic colorectal cancer were very
successful.
Yeah.
You could argue BRAF, EGFR inhibitors, these are things that you could think about.
Sure. Okay.
Okay. Could you please introduce yourself first?
Sure. Yeah. Philip Boscia, I'm actually a urologist from
Philadelphia.
I'm curious, we sort of have this idea in bladder as well, and
part of the problem we run into is the assessment of residual disease is
difficult. How good is the assessment for residual disease in
rectal cancer, and has there ever been a study where maybe you
assess it the way you typically would and then do
an APR or whatever it is anyway and actually determine if there's pathological
residual disease?
Yeah, it's a great question. There are many studies in rectal cancer that
do involve surgery mandatory for every patient.
Part of the intent was to avoid surgery-
Yeah
... which is why we did it this way. We know that patients when they get
chemotherapy as part of the PROSPECT study, which was done by Dr.
Schrag at our center. In the PROSPECT study, all the patients had surgery, and we
know that after they had chemotherapy, about 20% of them had a complete
pathologic response to tissue. So you certainly could predict,
looking under the microscope if there's still tumor there.
But then the patients have to get surgery, and for many patients, it's a
life-changing operation. They have a permanent ostomy bag for the rest of their
life.
Right.
So, it would change the study intent, but-
I'm not suggesting to-
Oh, sure.
My question is, how often is clinical complete response actually
pathologic complete response?
So most of the time,
clinical complete response does a great job.
Probably about 80% of the patients that have a complete clinical response
eventually after five years don't have their disease come back or more-
Okay
... depending what study you read.
Great. Thanks.
It's pretty good. So it's small numbers of patients in our study that the
recurrence rate was higher.
To follow up on that, you indicated that endoscopy and biopsy were
done. So was that done on all patients?
The four patients relapsed fairly early on at
four months, suggesting that they probably had
residual disease, but the question of whether it was a path
CR is of interest. What type of biopsy was
done and probably a more definitive biopsy that's not an
APR is a surgical excisional biopsy, not an
endoscopic needle biopsy. So what type of biopsy was done?
Yeah, it's a great question. So you kind of hit the nail on the head.
It was an endoscopic biopsy. All the patients had the same assessments, which was
rectal MRI, CAT scan, and endoscopic biopsy, and that was done. And you're right.
De facto, by having a recurrence, the patients must have had
microscopic disease that wasn't detected.
I think we have another person with a question.
Mike Skyking from UCL. So I wasn't going to ask you a question, but the question
came about chemotherapy avoidance.
So as you know, there's lots of next-generation HER2-targeted agents,
anadacitabine, TDHD.
And
we're trying to avoid giving chemo, and you could also give this treatment for much
longer. So because it's a relatively small study, and
obviously, Andrea has beautifully kind of demonstrated many great things
in rectum.
Is there a way you can almost do like an octopus study where you would put in new
agents and maybe use those? Because it's a pretty safe thing to do.
It looks like you're getting very good initial clinical response, but what you're
losing is the durability response.
So-
Right
... the answer to how you might be able to design that study.
Yeah, it's a great question. So to try and omit chemotherapy as well or?
Yeah, it's very provocative. I mean, you saw the early six-week period, it was just
basically two cycles of the HER2-only treatment, and the CTDNA for
many of the patients nearly cleared.
We had one or two patients that had a near CR just to HER2 therapy
alone.I think the problem with HER2 that we've found in other
GI intestinal diseases, and we're sort of catching up in colorectal, is the
heterogeneity. So the concern would be you might have these HER2 amplified
clones, but
there may be some clones there that really need the chemotherapy.
But to your excellent point, I think if you designed a study where there was a
stepwise approach where, say, you have a complete response and then maybe
you can avoid chemo. You don't, you continue with chemo.
You'd have to make sure that it was a true complete response and you keep an eye on
people. But I think something like that could be approached.
And I think it's an important point also to mention, we keep a really close eye on
people when they have a complete clinical response.
They're assessed very frequently with scopes, scans.
So all of the patients that recurred, they were salvageable without surgery because
we caught things very early. The first patient just had a tiny polyp, and there was
a tiny focus inside of the polyp of residual disease.
So I think as long as you keep your eyes on patients really closely, you can employ
bolder initiatives to try and spare people from toxicity.
Thank you.
Okay. Thank you very much.
I have a slide at the end to kind of try to pull everything together and wrap
it up in talking about neoadjuvant therapies.
But actually when I think about this, this is also not neoadjuvant in the
sense that this, in many ways, was definitive therapy for many
patients.
So we'll move to Dr. Fundameric Bernstam
from MD Anderson, and will present a Phase 2
single-arm open-label trial evaluating zenodatumab in
patients with early-stage HER2 positive breast cancer, the
NEO3NHER study.
Thank you so much. On behalf of my co-authors, it's really my pleasure to
talk to you about our Phase 2 neoadjuvant study in early-stage HER2 positive breast
cancer.
Here are my disclosures.
The treatment of HER2 positive breast cancer has been really evolving with a lot
of
changes, including routine use of neoadjuvant therapy for
high-risk breast cancer and emerging role for ADCs.
The APT trial showed that in patients with small lymph node
negative HER2 positive breast cancer, the outcomes with chemotherapy and
trastuzumab are excellent. But several studies now have
suggested by simple HER2 targeted therapies, there
may be pathological complete responses.
Further, there's now effective rescue therapies with HER2
ADCs. So as the HER2 targeted therapies evolve,
there's great interest in omitting chemotherapy altogether for early
stage breast cancer.
Zenodatumab is a biparatropic HER2 antibody.
It binds HER2 in two separate sites, the same domains that bind
trastuzumab and pertuzumab. This leads to increased tumor cell
binding, inhibition of cell signaling, and tumor cell growth, and
ADCC.
Zenodatumab's now FDA approved for HER2
3+ biliary tract cancer.
We asked the question of whether zenodatumab would be
efficacious in patients with HER2 positive
small tumors, looking at pathological complete response as our
endpoint. The secondary objectives included residual cancer
burden, which is a metric that looks at minimal residual disease in
the tumor, in the breast, as well as radiographic
response, tolerability, and safety.
Simply feasibility of this approach, as well as biomarkers of response.
We started the study with the design of giving zenodatumab 20
milligrams per kilogram every two weeks for three months.
After the first 11 patients, we recognized that there were
patients that not only had PCR, but we had several patients that
had residual disease burden of one, meaning a
limited amount of disease left in the breast.
We hypothesized that maybe going a little longer would increase our
PCR rates. Ultimately, we revised it to go with
10 doses, approximately five months.
So patients received assessment with ultrasound and
MRI, received zenodatumab. After six
weeks, they got repeat imaging, continued zenodatumab, and then
either
in cycle three or cycle five,
about a
few days after the treatment, went to surgery.
The adjuvant post-surgical treatment was left at the physician's discretion.
We enrolled 20 patients. Forty-five percent of the patients had tumors greater
than two centimeters. Seventy-five percent of the patients were HER2
3+. The rest of the patients were 2+ with HER2 amplification.
Eighty percent of the patients were ER positive.
Patients that were ER positive were also allowed to get endocrine therapy
by investigator discretion. Most of the patients did.
Zenodatumab was very well tolerated.
There were no new safety signals. Low-grade diarrhea
was the most common treatment-related adverse event.
There were no Grade 3 or higher treatment-related adverse events.
Overall, six patients, 30%, had
pathological complete response.
An additional 20% of the patients had residual cancer
burden of one.
No clinical variables were associated with PCR, albeit we had a limited
sample size. Notably, all patients that had a PCR
were IHC 3+.
Here's an example. On the left, you can see a patient on MRI
had a significant tumor that within six weeks of treatment had
resolution on their imaging.
Pathologically, this patient went on to have a complete pathological response.
Radiographically, all patients had an ultrasound before and then
on treatment.
Looking at those 20 patients that did,
overall, there was a significant decrease in tumor size as well as tumor
volume by ultrasound.17 patients had a pre and
on-treatment MRI. Patients had a significant decrease of
tumor size and tumor volume by MRI.
Seventeen patients had ultrasound preoperatively.
Looking at the patients that had PCR, these patients had a greater
drop in their tumor size on ultrasound compared to those patients that
did not have a PCR.
Radiographically, prior to surgery, five patients had
complete radiographic response.
On pathology, three of those patients had a PCR, one patient had
RCB 1, another had RCB 2.
For patients that had residual disease, we also looked at the residual
HER2 status.
So on 14 patients, we assessed this by IHC.
Nine of the patients had started off with 3+ at baseline in this group.
Fifty-six percent of the patients had a decrease in their HER2
expression.
Three of the patients were now 2+, one patient was 1+,
and one patient was HER2 ultra-low.
I should point out that patients went to the operating room shortly after the last
dose, so it's possible that this is HER2 downregulation by treatment
rather than HER2-positive tumors being
eliminated. For patients at the
baseline, we assessed whole exome sequencing and RNA sequencing
using the Baserome platform.
All four patients that had PCR on whole exome sequencing had
ERBB2 amplification. RNA expression was significantly
higher in the 12 patients with HER2 IHC 3+ compared to patients
that were 2+ or amplified by ISH.
HER2 RNA expression was numerically higher in patients that had
PCR compared to patients without PCR, although this does not
reach statistical significance.
We used the RNA-seq to derive PAM50
subtypes. Eleven of the 16 patients had
HER2-enriched classification, which in the figures are referred to as HER2
high.
Twenty-five percent of the patients were luminal B.
Patients that were HER2 IHC 3+ were more likely to be HER2 high
based on PAM50 classification compared to patients that were IHC
2+.
Three of four patients that were luminal B were HER2 IHC
All patients with PCR and six out of seven patients that were
RCB 0 or 1 had PAM50 HER2 high
tumors.
We looked at genomic features with whole exome sequencing.
Patients without PCR had a more genomically diverse tumor.
As I mentioned, all four patients with PCR had ERBB2
amplification. They also had PIK3 mutations.
Notably, one of the patients who had PCR also had an activating PTEN
mutation.
We also assessed the immune microenvironment.
The tumor microenvironment was classified into four based on
previously described subtypes.
Non-fibrotic subtypes dominated the cohort.
Three out of four patients that were IHC 2+ had tumors that were
immune desert subtype.
Patients that had better responses more frequently had immune-enriched
tumors, but this was not statistically significant.
Overall, in our study, we saw that zateduatumab
with endocrine therapy if they're ER positive was associated with robust
anti-tumor activity and manageable safety profile in patients with
node-negative, one to three centimeter, HER2 positive breast
cancer.
Omitting chemotherapy, just giving targeted therapy alone in
patients with early-stage breast cancer is feasible.
All patients in this study that had PCR were HER2 3+,
had ERBB2 amplification on whole exome sequencing, were HER2
subtype high on PAM50, and there was a trend
towards higher HER2 RNA expression.
PCR in this study was not dependent on ER status.
Translational studies are still needed to be able to assess early response so
we can determine when to escalate and add chemotherapy, and determine when
it's safe to continue de-escalation.
I'd like to conclude by thanking the multidisciplinary breast cancer team at MD
Anderson. And this study is an investigator study that was funded
initially by Zymeworks and then by Jazz Pharmaceuticals.
Most importantly, I thank our patients, their families,
and caregivers. Thank you.
This paper is open for discussion.
It's very hard to see, so if we don't see you, please speak up.
So Funda, it seems that
you're looking for the biomarker to identify those a
priori who can get by without chemotherapy, and
maybe it's going to be as many as 30% to 50% of these patients.
But
I guess the question is, the AJCC staging, the
TNM, has sort of been the foundation of how we select
treatments. But do you think that these biomarkers will
transcend that such that,
for example, although these were node-negative patients,
that even node-positive patients with these
biomarker signatures can avoid chemotherapy?
Yeah. That's an excellent question.
I do think by expanding our study, maybe we can do
better in refining. There may be a signal
there with the HER2 IHC 3+ and clearly additional molecular profiling
that can further refine. Ultimately, of
course, just the response is a way to move
forward because current practice for these patients to operate first
if they're less than two centimeters and then add chemotherapy
afterwards. So giving neoadjuvant therapy and assessing response,
and then determining who truly is responding and
then adding chemotherapy, there's no signal is the way to go, I
think. So we're looking now at what else we can add.
Is there a role for molecular imaging?
There's been some suggestion of role of PET scan.
Can we add strategies such as ctDNA to look at clearance of
ctDNA to further refine and decide on
sort of an early decision of add chemotherapy and continue versus
continue with targeted therapy only and add chemotherapy in the
adjuvant setting if needed.
Right.
And relative to use of chemotherapy, can you discuss a little bit
about the thoughts and the study design on timing between last dose of
molecular therapy and surgery?
Yeah. Thanks so much. So in this particular study, we
did the operation actually, either one day
later or a few four more days after, with the goal of
looking at the pathway inhibition.
Some of those studies have not been concluded.
So thus, when we got the HER2 IHC result
back, that could be a sign that HER2 is downregulated due
to zanidarabine, not just that we eradicated the HER2
positive clone. So we will be comparing pretreatment
and the residual disease, cell signaling
biomarkers, as well as immune subtype
further to be able to look at that. But definitely I think
from a timing standpoint,
that not getting full credit from that last couple of weeks probably is not an
issue. And zani is a very safe drug, so there's no perioperative
concerns of giving the drug right before surgery.
Right. But so the study design, though, was based on
scientifically getting pharmacodynamic information-
Yes
... as opposed to perhaps maximizing-
Yes, that's correct.
Sorry. I had a quick question, and I think we have another person with a question.
So
I was just wondering, did you show what kind
of chemotherapy the patients who did not-- Or what kind of
therapy patients who did not obtain a
PCR have?
Yeah. Thanks so much. So,
the patients that had PCR or RCB1
all went on to just get targeted therapy.
So those patients had either zani or zani plus endocrine therapy.
And patients that had RCB2 or greater
got a mishmash of chemotherapy based on investigator choice.
So some of those patients went on to get paclitaxel and
trastuzumab.
Two of the patients went on to get T-DM1.
Right.
And then a few of the patients got pertuzumab, trastuzumab, and docetaxel.
So that was not standardized, but all patients are
doing well.
Sure. I would think that, I mean, I applaud you
for conducting such a trial because I would think it's very difficult to
explain to a patient if they received standard of care
APT.
They would have excellent survival and tolerability.
Yet, should you not achieve a PCR, they may
potentially end up with more chemotherapy.
And with your objective being trying to identify a
population who you can omit chemotherapy.
Yeah, that's an excellent point. But of course, patients that get APT get
chemotherapy, and then they still get a full year to
complete trastuzumab for a year. So really when you think about it, we're bringing
the HER2 target therapy in the beginning and looking at that response
to gate who really needs chemotherapy.
I see.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Yeah, I thought this was a gift up here for me, but now I realize why this had us
up here. I can actually see there's somebody on the right side. Please.
Thank you. Thank you very much. Very interesting.
There's already one approved assay for
HER2 positive patients, which HER2DX.
I don't know if you have been able to assess the
samples with HER2DX.
Yeah. Thanks so much. We're actually in discussions to see if we can look at
HER2DX.
Thank you.
Okay.
Okay. Thank you, Funda.
Okay,
next
we would like to introduce Dr. Balak from the University of
Pittsburgh presenting data from NSABP.
Thank you. Thank you very much.
Thanks to the organizers for selecting our abstract to be presented here
in this clinical symposium.
I would like to have my
mic.
Okay.
So,
on behalf of my co-authors, I would like to present our data on whole
exome sequencing tumor-informed circulating tumor DNA detection
after completion of neoadjuvant treatment,
predicting non-PCR and distant recurrence in patients with early
triple-negative breast cancer. These are results from a substudy
of the NSABP B-59, GBG 96
GEPRDUOS trial.
Here are my disclosures of note. None of them are related to the topic
of presentation. I would like to acknowledge the support of the
NSABP B-59 and GBG 96 GEPRDUOS trial,
which was funded by Genentech and Roche, and the substudy was
funded by Exact Sciences.
Here is the study design of the parental study.
The NSABP B-59 or GEPRDUOS parent study
was performed in 1,550 patients
randomizing patients to the maximum of chemotherapy with
paclitaxel carboplatin followed by AC or
EC randomized to either receive
atezolizumab or placebo. After surgery, patients
completed up to a year of adjuvant treatment with atezolizumab.
In
212 patients, the substudy was performed to collect ctDNA
at baseline post neoadjuvant treatment, pre-surgery two to
four weeks post completion of neoadjuvant treatment,
post-surgery, and at two and 24 months during the
follow-up. Median follow-up time was 37 months.
At San Antonio 2025 in December, we presented the
post-surgery ctDNA positivity impacting the risk
of recurrence with a hazard ratio of
30.395% of patients who were
MRD negative at
post-surgical time point were recurrence-free at three years.
For this analysis, we have analyzed 173 patients
with 147 post-surgery ctDNA results.
At today's presentation, I am focusing on post neoadjuvant treatment
pre-surgery ctDNA time point as a treatment response
decision time point with the question whether ctDNA clearance
post neoadjuvant treatment predicts pathological complete response,
and does post neoadjuvant treatment ctDNA may predict distant
recurrence independently. For this analysis,
155 patients with pre-surgery ctDNA results
were included. The objective of this analysis was to evaluate the
association between post neoadjuvant ctDNA
status in both PCR and distant recurrence in
the same prospective cohort.
We employed the OncoDetect tumor-informed ctDNA
assay. For variant discovery, this assay uses whole
exome sequencing of primary tumor at 400 to
800X, and for subtraction of germline
information, sequencing at 100X of peripheral
mononuclear cells is used. Up to 200 somatic
variants not present in germline are identified for each
patient, and in our case, a median of
164 somatic variants was identified with a
range of 42 to 200. For ctDNA
detection, plasma samples were hybridized to bespoke
patient-specific probe set. A very high
success rate of sequencing was observed with
98.4%, and the ctDNA detection
or sample positivity was determined using a
proprietary algorithm.
And these are the ctDNA positivity rates.
As shown on the left-hand side, in 160 baseline
patients, 96% were ctDNA positive.
After completion of neoadjuvant treatment,
9% remained ctDNA positive, and after
completion of surgery, only 6% of patients remained
ctDNA positive. Among patients with baseline
positive ctDNA who also had a post neoadjuvant
blood draw, the matched samples were in 136
patients, 90.4% of patients cleared
ctDNA with neoadjuvant treatment.
And here is the correlation of ctDNA status in
pathological complete response.
In patients who were post neoadjuvant treatment ctDNA negative,
95 patients achieved pathological complete response, and
46 patients did not achieve a pathological complete
response. For those patients who were ctDNA positive at
completion, only two patients achieved pathological complete
response, whereas 12 did not achieve pathological complete response.
This related to our ctDNA positivity
has shown a 97.9% specificity
for non-PCR and 85.7 positive
predictive value for not achieving pathological complete response.
Here are results for ctDNA clearance during neoadjuvant treatment.
For patients who were ctDNA positive at baseline and remained
ctDNA positive, 11 patients or
84.6% did not achieve pathological complete
response, and two or 15.4 did achieve
pathological complete response.
For patients who cleared ctDNA,
we observed 38 or 30.9% of patients
not achieving pathological complete response, whereas
69% or 85 patients achieved pathological
complete response. Summarized, 85% of
patients with persistent ctDNA detected post neoadjuvant
treatment did not achieve pathological complete response, whereas almost
70% of patients who cleared ctDNA after neoadjuvant
treatment did achieve pathological complete response.
We evaluated the ctDNA concentration and tumor
burden according to number of mutated
molecules per milliliter of
plasma at baseline, and you clearly can observe that there is
a statistical significant correlation according to the tumor
size as shown on the left, and according to the lymph node status
as shown on the right of the slide.
Here are the results of post neoadjuvant ctDNA
value and distant recurrence
interval. And what you can clearly observe is that patients who were
pre-surgery or post neoadjuvant treatment negative,
6% or nine out of 141 patients
developed recurrence, whereas in those patients who were ctDNA
positive, seven out of 13 or 54%
developed recurrence, representing a hazard ratio of
10.2 in the statistically
significant result with a P of 0.0001.
As a reminder, these were the results of the post-surgery
ctDNA positivity as
presented at San Antonio 25. And here the
hazard ratio was 30.3 with
some differences. There were some additional patients who cleared ctDNA with
surgery in addition to neoadjuvant treatment.
This represents a more granular result,
clearly showing, although no statistical evaluation could be performed due to
small numbers, that patients who were ctDNA negative,
even if they remained with non-pathological complete
response or had residual cancer, did much better and almost
as good as patients with pathological complete response and
ctDNA negativity.To conclude,
building on our prior findings, post-neoadjuvant treatment
pre-surgery ctDNA positivity was strongly associated with
inferior distant recurrence-free interval with a hazard ratio of
10.2, mirroring the negative prognostic impact
previously observed and presented for post-surgery
ctDNA, where the hazard ratio was 30.3.
This post-neoadjuvant ctDNA positivity
showed a high positive predictive value for non-pathological complete
response, highlighting its potential utility as an early
indicator of treatment resistance, risk stratification, and
potentially adaptation of treatment.
These studies will help define suitable time points for
escalation and de-escalation strategies.
And with this, I would like to thank all patients who participated in our
trial and their families, all investigators and the research
staff of NSABP, GBG, GICAM, EUSSER, and
TRIO who participated and supported the trial, to the
headquarter teams of NSABP, GBG, and IDDI,
members of the DCMB of NSABP and GBG
GEPARD DUOS parent trial, and to Genentech
and Roche for funding, support of the development, conduct, and
in the analysis of the parent trial.
And to conclude, these are all the affiliations of the
contributors to the trial, demonstrating that it takes a lot of effort to
complete such a large trial and the clinical substudy. Thank you.
Okay.
I don't see any questions now, but I have a couple.
Thank you for that wonderful presentation.
I was just struck by how much
your results mirrored that of the I-SPY trial
that was written up by, I think, Meg Buona et al.
Yeah.
The rate of ctDNA after neoadjuvant therapy,
I believe was
almost identical to yours.
So a couple of questions. In at San Antonio,
you demonstrated
the effect of having a positive ctDNA
after surgery, and now you present today
the rate of positivity
after neoadjuvant therapy pre-surgery.
I had always wondered what the act of surgery did to a
ctDNA level. When you remove the tumor, does that
actually change the concentration of the ctDNA or the
positivity rate at all? And I was wondering, since you had that
data, whether you were able to look at that question.
So at that time point, this was probably the largest series
of the samples that we were able to analyze.
But still, when you come to this question, the numbers are small.
Mm-hmm.
We did observe additional three patients who cleared
ctDNA based on the surgery, and the hazard ratio
was much larger even than the pre-neoadjuvant treatment,
definitely implicating that surgery does have additional value for
those patients who remain with the resistant disease.
But we will need larger meta-analysis and joint analysis to
really define that question.
Sure. So it seems like rather than just relying on
RCB1, 2, 3, we're really looking at
a future where we'll be combining
the ctDNA status at the end of therapy
along with the surgical results. And I think you're right, we will need very large
studies to be able to understand how we can use that to-
I agree. And those are two different time points-
Yeah
... pre-neoadjuvant or post-neoadjuvant treatment.
But pre-surgery allows us to potentially escalate
additional systemic treatment to even have more patients who
achieve pathological complete response.
Mm-hmm.
While after surgery, there is this question of post-neoadjuvant treatment
trials where we could still salvage those who remain ctDNA
positive.
I think I see someone with a question over there.
Yeah. Thank you for the nice talk. Hyungdon Kim from Korea, Asan
Medical Center.
There are actually two patients who achieved PCR but were
positive for ctDNA after neoadjuvant treatment.
So could you be more specific about their characteristics or their
clinical outcomes?
So as shown, we have
shown very clearly demonstrated that ctDNA negativity is clearly
associated with long-term outcomes.
We will have to look into the level of ctDNA positivity
for those patients who did achieve a pathological complete response to
still see
whether they clear longer. But overall,
most of the patients who were ctDNA positive relapsed, and there
was a high enrichment towards the ctDNA positivity.
Okay, perfect. Thank you.
And then you teased us with your conclusion slide, saying that it
helps define the timing to determine
escalation and de-escalation therapies.
Now, I'm going to assume that de-escalation is not going to be in the surgical
realm, although theoretically,
path CR, those patients don't benefit from surgery.
But presumably you're talking more about escalating or de-escalating adjuvant
therapy. Is that right?
There are several components to this.
As soon as we become comfortable with de-escalating the
neoadjuvant treatment, it's also de-escalating the duration of the treatment as
long as patients clear ctDNA. So this is one potential
option, and then of course, afterwards where we
feel probably most comfortable at the moment is escalating treatment for
those who are at risk who remain ctDNA positive to try to salvage them
and save their lives.
Okay, wonderful.
I had a quick question, sorry.
Oh, sorry about that. Yes.
No worries. I think I just wanted to ask, what was the sample used
forDoing the whole exome sequencing, and also what was the failure rate of the
assay?
What was the failure rate?
Failure rate specifically of the design.
I've shown that
it was very highly successful with 98%
of samples being successfully sequenced
for design of the tumor-informed assay,
and it's 400 to 800 ex sequencing depending on the
region of interest and the sequencing was performed with exome.
What was the source of the samples?
Sorry, was it biopsy or was it surgical samples?
It's typically the biopsy.
Okay, thanks.
Okay, thank you.
I'd like to ask Dr. Yilong Wu to come to the stage from Guangdong
Lung Cancer Institute to present perioperative atezolizumab plus
chemotherapy in resectable stage two/three non-small cell lung
cancer, a phase III event-free
survival interim analysis and molecular residual disease
analysis.
Yeah. Good afternoon, everybody.
It's my honor to be here to present our
phase III clinical trial, the perioperative
atezolizumab plus the chemotherapy in
resectable stage two to stage three non-small cell
cancer. This is a phase III clinical trial, and we are
combining our molecular
residual disease analysis.
This is my disclosure.
So
atezolizumab is the IgG4
anti-PD-L1 antibody. In
part one, the phase one clinical trial, we have to show the benefit
society, the efficacy, and the safety profile.
So we developed this, the phase III clinical
trial, to evaluate
in this perioperative setting. Also, as
you know, the molecular residual disease is very important
as the prognosis or the
predictive factor to guide our treatment.
So a comprehensive MRD program
was incorporated into this phase III study to
evaluate the ctDNA dynamic and data associated with the
pathological and the clinical outcome.
Here we report the interim analysis of the
event-free survival and explore the MRD result
from the phase III study of the perioperative
atezolizumab plus chemotherapy for
resectable non-small cell lung cancer.
So this is a study design. We are
including the
AJCC eighth version,
stage two to stage three, the non-small cell lung cancer, and
exclude the EGR and ALK fusion,
and all the patients with the PD-L1
expression assessment. We use three
factors as the stratification factor.
One is the PD-L1 expression, the
second the clinical stage, and last the
historical squamous versus non-small cell cancer.
All the patients randomized to
treatment and atezolizumab 20 milligram a kilo plus the
chemotherapy,
four cycle. And the
control arm, the placebo plus the chemotherapy, also
three pre-treatment
cycle arm. And after surgery, the
treatment arm continued until the 16
cycles. And about the ctDNA,
before the treatment, we have the baseline, the
C1D1, the ctDNA test.
And pre-surgery, we are once again test the
ctDNA. And after the surgery in the adjuvant
setting, the C1D1, we are also test the
ctDNA. And after then,
Q3 we amount to test the
ctDNA. This clinical trial, the primary
endpoint, the EFS by the PERC and the
MPR by the PERC. And then secondly, including
the overall survival, safety data, and so on.
So this is our statistic consideration.
First, we test the MPR. With the
MPR,
40% versus the control arm, the 50%.
If the method is correct here, then we are
continue test the EFS. The EFS,
we
extend
the 83 patients with the
229 target, this has to result zero system
error.
Totally, we have the 501 cases in total
clinical trial.
This is the patient disposition. All the patients
received the three cycle,
the immunotherapy and the treatment.
And after this, the three cycle, only
1.2% of the patients, the digital progression during the treatment,
comparing the placebo arm,
5.2% digital progression during the treatment.
And then the 88.8% of patients
received the surgery compared to placebo arm,
83.4% of patients received
surgery.After the surgery,
63.7%, comparing the
adjuvant treatment,
maintain about
11.2% patient
experience the digital progression, comparing the placebo arm,
24% patient in the digital progression.
So this is the baseline, the characteristic.
All the subgroup, including the
age, smoking status, histology,
ECO performance, clinical stage, and PD-L1,
all the balance between these two groups.
So this is our primary endpoint, the
EFS. The primary endpoint is not
imagined, but the heart ratio 0.2,
P-value, let's say 001. The event in the
active regimen,
about 24.7%, and the placebo arm,
the
38.4%. At the two-year, the
EFS rate, 74.8% versus the
55.5% patient. The heart ratio
0.45 for the investigation
evaluation.
EFS per protocol in the subgroup, or the group protocol
in favor of the ado-trastuzumab plus the chemotherapy.
How about the MPR and the PCR? The MPR in the
ado-trastuzumab plus the chemotherapy, about
53.8%, versus the placebo
18.4%. The difference
35.6% among these two
group. The PCR in the treatment arm
31.1% versus the
7.6%. The difference about
23.7%.
So about the MPR and the PCR in the
subgroup, all the data showed all the subgroup
in favor of
the ado-trastuzumab plus the chemotherapy arm.
This is the overall survival, the trend.
So for the data is the imagined, but the
event in the ado-trastuzumab about the
12.7% versus placebo the
21%, the heart ratio
0.57. The trend
showed
in favor of the treatment, but I think we
need a more long
follow out.
So how the safety profile, I think this is very
important data. So all the treatment AE
identified here, most relate to the chemotherapy.
But for the IO,
the side effect, grade 3,
4.4% versus the placebo 1.6%,
and leading to dose discontinued
5.2% versus the 0.8%. So I think
therefore the PD-L1 inhibitor, the
IE relate is very lower. So most
toxicity relate to the chemotherapy.
So how about the CTDA clean and the MPR, the
PCR relationship? Here we are showing you the patient
with the pre-surgery CTDA clearing in the
ado-trastuzumab were more likely to treat
MPR and the PCR than the placebo arm.
So here, about the ado-trastuzumab,
44.7% CTDA cleared
in this group,
37.1% achieved the
MPR. But for the placebo arm, the most of the
patient, no MPR patient. For the
PCR patient, 44.7%
the CTDA clear and
25.8% achieved the PCR. For the
placebo arm, there's no
this data.
So CTDA clearance and the clinical outcome.
So here they show you the pre-surgery
CTDA clearance was associated with the improved
EFS in the both arm with the trend toward longer
EFS with the ado-trastuzumab versus placebo, irrespective
of the clearance. Here show you the CTDA clearance at
the pre-surgery for the CTDA clear, the
treatment and the control arm almost the same.
At the age of the C1, D1 all the same.
But for the CTDA not clear,
apparently adjuvant
ado-trastuzumab is the better than the
control arm for
at the
pre-surgery and the C1 and the D1.
So in conclusion, perioperative
ado-trastuzumab plus the chemotherapy significantly
improved EFS and the MPR compared with
placebo plus the chemotherapy. The EFS two-year
rate, 74.8% versus the
55.1%, heart ratio 0.2.
Definitely the surgery and the PCR rate were also improved with the
ado-trastuzumab plus the chemotherapy.
Benefit in the pathological and the clinical outcome were
considered cross subgroupAnd the
early trend in the favor of the atezolizumab plus the
chemotherapy was observed in the overall survival.
Two-year rate, 89.1% versus the
80.6% had result 057. And
the safety profile was manageable and consistent with the
individual agent. ctDNA dynamically
predict the pathological and clinical
outcome, providing a potential tool for
refined peri-operation risk stratification.
Our finding support the peri-operative atezolizumab
plus the chemo as a new treatment option for the resectable
stage two and stage three non-small cell cancer.
Finally, I would like to thank all the patient and the family, and
all the investigator. This is star support, the Jiangsu
Hengrui Pharmaceutical Company. Thank you for attention.
Thank you. This paper is open for discussion.
So in all of these
presentations, the dynamic information
obtained through the ctDNA is very informative
to tailor therapy, and it's notable
that in the cycle one, day one
complete clearance of ctDNA that they didn't benefit from the
immuno-- or there's no improvement with the immunotherapy.
And so is cycle one, day one ctDNA
perhaps an opportunity to avoid the...
They got 16 cycles outback, 13 cycles
outback?
Yeah, I think this is a very good question.
Our ctDNA
protocol, we are tested
at the baseline, not any treatment.
And then after neoadjuvant treatment, before the surgery, we
are tested ctDNA. But I think two point is very important.
One point is after the neoadjuvant, and then
second point after the surgery, and this both the
negative will mean that it's cleared.
Most
ctDNA clearance occurred after the neoadjuvant.
But after the surgery, also some of the patient continued the
clearance. So I think if we want to in this setting,
these two point is we call this a landmark, is very
important. So this is both
the clearance, I think this is very good
predictor of the outcome. And also in
this trial, we are not so far our
longitude test. I think this longitude
maybe in the next year we are with the proper
result.
Okay. I'm sorry. And to that point, could you remind us what
that time point pre-surgery
at the end of neoadjuvant therapy was?
Mm-hmm.
What was the ctDNA positivity rate?
Yes, we have the pre-surgery and after surgery. Yeah.
Okay. What was the percentage of positivity?
The positivity?
Positive ctDNA
before surgery.
Yeah. I think before the surgery,
I think only the 10% difference.
10%. Okay. So that mirrors a lot of what we saw in the breast cancer
data too where after cycle one,
about 50% are positive, but then
at the end of neoadjuvant therapy, you're looking at a small number of patients
who most of who-
I think maybe the-
... did not do well.
Lung cancer is something different from the breast cancer.
A little bit different, yeah.
We have a question on the microphone on the right.
Hang on.
Oh, we can't hear you.
For this allergy. Yeah.
I think the mic might be turned off.
Was it?
Okay.
Okay, we'll come back to you in a second.
Yes.
There's someone on the left here.
Yeah.
I just had a question on the,
as we advance the PDL1
drugs, specifically IgG4 here into peri-operative settings, into
neoadjuvant-based settings,
if you could comment on immune-related adverse events associated with these, and
are you seeing more immune-related adverse events, or have you started to explore
those sorts of things
in this patient population as compared to
in the metastatic setting, late stage setting that
Adebri has already been approved for?
Did you hear that question?
You're asking about toxicity, right?
Yeah, immune-related adverse events. Correct.
So the question is, in the neoadjuvant setting, is the toxicity any different than
in the metastatic setting?
Yeah, I think
we are also some debate in the non-small cell lung cancer.
We are only use the neoadjuvant setting, or we need a
peri-operative, but this always argue.
So
for the treatment, everyone is only use the three cycle, and then
the very good result. So I think in all the
clinical trial, we don't
answer your question, the adjuvant important or
not so important. But I think
we can
based on the ctDNA clearance to guide our adjuvant
treatment timeline. I think, but this is the newer future, and we
need
the prospective clinical trial to validate this.
I think you can maybe get a clearer answer on the side afterwards.
On the right.
Let's try it if it works now. So I just wanted to ask because I may have
missed it, which assay did you use for the ctDNA detection?
It was quite striking that although some patients cleared,
they didn't do as well. What was the assay used?
Or ctDNA.
What was the assay
that was used?
So not so clear, yeah?
Are you asking what assay was used?
Yes.
Okay. She's asking what assay
was used.
How was it tested? What assay?
Oh, how is it tested? Okay. I think in
China, we have a lot of
the NGS company to test the MRD.
But
in this clinical trial, we are using some at the wonder company
there with the tumor-informed. That
has not the
tumor engrossed, the
test. Yeah.
Okay.
I just wanted to clarify whether you excluded patients with
targetable mutations and if not,
was there any difference in the outcomes since they're not particularly
sensitive to the chemo immuno combination?
I didn't catch it. Did you catch it?
I did not.
So-
Would you mind repeating that question a little more simply?
In your eligibility criteria, did you exclude patients with
targetable mutations, or are they included in the cohort?
Exclusion.
Did you exclude PALB2 mutations?
What?
PALB2.
PALB.
P-A-L-B.
PRB? Yeah. Okay. I think
in our clinical trial, we have
no the PRB for this patient. But I think
we also want the program how to test the
PRB about
the immunotherapy microenvironment.
So this is the next step, but not our clinical trial.
Those patients were included?
Yeah.
And probably in the non-smokers. Did you analyze
any of them? Were you able to identify that they had worse outcomes
and maybe they're a significant part of your ctDNA
positive group?
Yeah. Okay.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, Dr. Yu, for the fantastic presentation.
Okay.
Next we'd like to welcome Dr. Cascone from MD
Anderson, who will be speaking about clinical outcomes by genomic markers
and ctDNA dynamics with perioperative nivolumab for
resectable non-small cell lung cancer from CheckMate 770.
Thank you. Thank you, co-chairs. Good afternoon, everyone.
On behalf of my co-authors and the CheckMate
770 investigators, I would like to thank the scientific committee for the
opportunity to present the clinical outcomes by
genomic markers and ctDNA dynamics with perioperative nivolumab
for resectable non-small cell lung cancer from CheckMate 770.
Here you have my disclosures.
So in the Phase 3 CheckMate 770 study, perioperative nivo
demonstrated statistically significant and clinically meaningful
EFS benefit versus placebo in patients with resectable non-small cell lung
cancer, and PCR rates were also improved.
Perioperative nivo is now approved in the United States and
European Union for eligible patients with resectable non-small cell lung
cancer. However,
patients with poor prognosis, including those with tumors harboring
distinct driver gene alterations, detectable ctDNA
before surgery and MRD after surgery,
represent a high unmet need. So today we
report comprehensive exploratory analysis of EFS by tumor genomic
alteration status and ctDNA dynamics from the CheckMate
770 to identify potential markers of efficacy
with perioperative therapy in patients with resectable non-small cell lung cancer.
In CheckMate 770, patients with previously untreated
resectable Stage 2 to 3 non-small cell lung cancer according to the
AJCC 8th editions with no EGFR mutations
and no known ALK translocations were randomized one-to-one
to perioperative nivo or placebo.
ctDNA was monitored throughout the neoadjuvant and adjuvant phases of the
study with a tumor-informed assay.
Exploratory analysis included genomic profiling through whole exome
sequencing, EFS or BCOR by tumor genomic alteration
status and ctDNA dynamics, as well as associations
between EFS and clinical or genomic markers based
on a random survival forest machine learning model.
Data presented today are from the December 16th,
2024 database lock with a median follow-up of 41
months.
Of 461 randomized patients, 41%
were biomarker evaluable with paired tumor and blood samples and
were included in this analysis. The most common reasons for
exclusion were tumors not passing pathology
evaluation, assay not being available in China, or tumor
samples failing whole exome sequencing.
Here, tumor genomic single and co-alteration prevalence is shown.
The bar charts show the number of patients with
alterations in each individual gene.
On the right,
you see the number of patients with different single or co-alteration
combinations, and you see the connected dots
indicating the type of combination of alterations and the single
dots indicating the single alterations.
The frequency of alterations was overall similar across treatment
arms,
and the most common single tumor alteration was TP53
mutation. The most common co-alterations were
TP53 mutation and CDKN2A alterations in both
treatment arms.We performed an EFS
analysis by tumor mutation status for KRAS, KEAP1,
or SDK11 as a single or co-mutation.
EFS was overall similar between nivo and placebo for patients with
KRAS mutations. In patients with KRAS wild-type tumors,
EFS appeared to be improved with nivo versus placebo, with a hazard ratio
of 0.6.
Among patients with KEAP1 mutations, the EFS as a
ratio for nivo was 0.6, and in KEAP1
wild-type patients, nivo appeared to prolong EFS as compared
to placebo, with a hazard ratio of 0.64.
Among patients with SDK11 mutations, the
EFS in favor of nivo versus placebo was at 0.63,
and in SDK11 wild-type tumors, EFS appeared to be
prolonged with nivo versus chemo placebo with a hazard ratio of
0.65. It's important to note that the sample
sizes for the analysis in the mutation
subgroups were small, and therefore, this data needs to be
interpreted with caution.
We performed an EFS analysis by single or co-alteration in at
least one of four genes known to be associated with poor
prognosis in non-small cell lung cancer: KEAP1, SDK11,
CDKN2A, and/or SMARCA4. On the
left, you can see that patients with at least one
alterations in any of these genes had EFS that appeared to be
improved with nivolumab as compared to placebo, with a hazard ratio of
0.48 and 30-month EFS rates of
60% versus 30%, respectively. On
the right, in patients with no alterations in any of these genes,
EFS was similar between treatment groups.
EFS with nivo was similar regardless of mutation
status in any of these four genes, whereas EFS with
placebo was worse in patients with at least one alteration in
any of these genes as compared to patients without.
As far as ctDNA dynamics in relation to PCR status,
46 patients in the nivo arm and 44 patients in the placebo
arm had evaluable ctDNA before neoadjuvant treatment and at
neoadjuvant treatment completion, had available PCR status, MRD
status before adjuvant treatment, and at least one additional time
point during the adjuvant period.
Of these patients, 87% in the nivo arm and
84% in the placebo arm had detectable ctDNA before
neoadjuvant treatment. So in this population, the rates of ctDNA
clearance before surgery were 75% in the nivo arm as
compared to 46% in the placebo arm.
PCR appeared to be associated with ctDNA clearance in
the nivo arm with a PCR rate of 70%, as
compared to 18% of patients with PCR
among those in the placebo arm who had ctDNA clearance.
Rates of MRD post definitive surgery were overall low
across treatment arms in patients with ctDNA clearance and regardless of
PCR status.
Among patients with baseline detectable ctDNA, 25% in
the nivo arm as compared to 54% in the placebo arm did
not have ctDNA clearance. Among those, almost none had a
PCR, and MRD rates were again
low for patients in the nivo arm. However, 42% of patients in
the placebo arm with no ctDNA clearance and no PCR
had MRD.
In patients with detectable ctDNA at baseline, EFS appeared
to be prolonged with nivo versus placebo, with a hazard ratio of 0.58.
As expected, patients with ctDNA clearance had prolonged EFS
as compared to patients without across both treatment arms, and
EFS appeared to be improved with nivo versus placebo in both
patients with ctDNA clearance and those without.
Landmark EFS from surgery appeared to be improved with nivo as
compared to placebo in MRD negative patients before
adjuvant treatment. Although the median EFS was not reached in either
treatment arm.
To identify potential predictors of EFS outcome, we applied a
machine learning model that was trained using data from 80% of
biomarker evaluable patients across both treatment arms
and tested using data from the remaining 20% of
biomarker evaluable patients, again, across both treatment arms.
This exploratory analysis revealed that ctDNA clearance before surgery,
non N2 nodal status, achieving a PCR,
squamous histology, and receiving treatment with perioperative nivo
were the most predictive factors for longer EFS in the
biomarker evaluable patient population from both treatment
arms.
SMARCA4 mutation, CDKN2A alteration, and
KEAP1 mutation had relatively less impact on
predicting EFS outcome, again, in the biomarker evaluable
population from both treatment arms.
In summary, perioperative nivo demonstrated consistent EFS
benefit as compared with placebo across clinical and genomic
subgroups.
EFS was similar with nivo regardless of tumor genomic
alteration status, but was worse with placebo in
patients with single or co-alterations in KEAP1,
SDK11, CDKN2A, and/or SMARCA4
versus patients without.
EFS outcomes were prolonged with nivo versus placebo across
all subgroups defined by ctDNA dynamics, and as
expected, ctDNA appeared to be prognostic for EFS in
patients with resectable non-small cell lung cancer.
From our predictive model, machine learning model with an
exploratory analysis, we learned that top predictors of prolonged EFS
were ctDNA clearance, non N2 nodal
statusPCR, squamous histology,
and perioperative nivo treatment, confirming known
drivers of clinical decision-making for administering
perioperative immunotherapy. However, at this time, and based on the
limited data that we have in this patient subset, less predictive markers
of EFS, including alterations in SMARCA4,
CDKN2A, and KEAP1, have an unclear role and should
not be used to direct perioperative therapy in this
setting. We need further investigation in larger cohorts to evaluate the
impact of these markers in the context of perioperative immunotherapy.
So in conclusion, these findings further support perioperative nivo as an
effective treatment option in eligible patients with resectable non-small
cell lung cancer and highlight potentially meaningful markers for
risk stratification.
I would like to thank all the patients and their families who made this study
possible, the clinical study teams who participated across 18
countries, the members of the team at Bristol Myers Squibb
for a wonderful support, and I would like to thank you all for your attention.
Okay. Any questions for Dr. Cascone?
Okay.
Oh, okay. So I think in the interest of time, we will-- Or did you
want?
One
topic that came up earlier, I don't know if you have the data, but
in the people who hadn't cleared ctDNA, did
surgery convert some of those people to complete clearance, and how
frequently?
Yes. So first of all, here in the CheckMate 77t, we had
two time points in the neoadjuvant setting.
So baseline, prior to cycle one, day one, and then prior to
surgery.
Okay.
And then we had four time points in the adjuvant setting.
So to your point,
it's a very important question. We do see that, of course, removal
tumor will minimize the sensitivity of the ctDNA
in the early stage phase.
I think for lung cancer, we are in a situation where in
the neoadjuvant setting, clearance of ctDNA is
not robust enough for us to have a sparing surgery
approach. But I think
more studies will be needed to assess this question.
Got it. Thank you.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
If we could ask Dr. Howard Lee to come to the podium from the Sidney Kimmel
Cancer Center to present Feasibility and Efficacy of Perioperative
Nivolumab with or without Relatimab for
Patients with Potentially Resectable Adenocarcinoma.
Thank you to all the organizers and everyone for their time and this opportunity to
present this work.
And so yeah, my name's Howard. I'm a medical student at Johns Hopkins, and on
behalf of my collaborators at Johns Hopkins, Ohio State, and
Bristol Myers Squibb's, I present to you Feasibility and Efficacy of
Perioperative Nivolumab with or without Relatimab for Patients with
Potentially Resectable HCC.
I have no financial disclosures, and funding for this trial was provided by BMS to
my PI, Dr. Mark Yarchoan.
First, some background. First-line treatment for early-stage HCC is surgical
resection and offers patients a chance for cure.
However, recurrence rates are significant in this cancer, with up to 80% of
patients recurring after surgery.
Currently, there are no standard or approved neoadjuvant or adjuvant systemic
therapies for resectable HCC, highlighting an urgent need for safe and feasible
systemic options in this setting.
Recently, there were two key negative Phase III adjuvant ICI trials in
HCC, including IMbrave050, the updated data, as well as
KEYNOTE-937. Both atezolizumab and bevacizumab, as well as
pembrolizumab monotherapy, did not show survival benefit over active surveillance
alone. This highlights the shift towards neoadjuvant and perioperative strategies.
Several studies recently of neoadjuvant therapies in HCC have
demonstrated both safety and feasibility as well as meaningful pathologic response
rates and tertiary lymphoid aggregate formation in
therapy recipients. In addition, pathologic responses have been correlated with
long-term survival as well. Just last year, the CARES-019
trial out of China was a Phase II/III trial for perioperative pembrolizumab with
rivicereb, a combination of PD-1 and anti-VEGF therapy
that showed superior event-free survival compared to active surveillance alone.
However, this regimen is not adopted by Western guidelines as overall
survival benefit has not yet been demonstrated.
And reflective of local HCC patterns in China, most
of the disease etiology in the cohort for this trial had
HPV-positive liver disease etiology.
This highlights that validation of their cohorts is necessary and additional data
is needed to identify the optimal perioperative regimen.
For the rationale for neoadjuvant nivolumab with relatimab, which is
anti-LAG3 monoclonal. First, fibrinogen-like 1 protein,
or FGL1, is a major inhibitory ligand of LAG3 and is
constitutively expressed in the liver.
An early HCC is actually enriched for adaptive immune resistance through this
pathway, along with the PD-1 pathway.
And dual PD-1 LAG3 blockade restores T cell function
beyond PD-1 blockade alone. And in our earlier neoadjuvant study
that combined nivolumab with cabozantinib, a multi-tyrosine kinase
inhibitor that also targets VEGF, identified higher expression of
LAG3 in the TILs and peripheral PBMCs of non-responders in that trial.
Also, in addition, perioperative nivolumab with
relatimab has shown benefit in other tumors such as melanoma.
However, this has not yet been studied in HCC.
And so here we present an open-label, non-comparative, randomized Phase II trial
for potentially resectable HCCFrom 2021 to '25,
patients were enrolled in Johns Hopkins and Ohio State's liver MDCs and were
randomized to receive two doses over eight weeks of either arm A,
480 milligrams of nivolumab, or arm B, 480 milligrams of nivolumab with
relatimab. Patients then underwent surgical resection, and eligible patients
continued to the adjuvant cycle of our trial.
The primary endpoint of our trial was feasibility, which was the number of patients
who experienced an unacceptable treatment-related adverse event that precluded
surgery. Secondary endpoints included proportion of complete or major pathologic
responses being defined as 90% or greater tumor necrosis.
Other secondary endpoints included objective response rate, disease-free, and
overall survival. And there were a couple of exploratory analyses, including LAG-3
receptor occupancy assays, as well as immunophenotyping of the TILs and the TME.
Our data cutoff was in November of last year.
And for table one of our trial here, we can see a diverse range of liver
disease etiologies, as well as a predominance of BCLC
stage A patients, as well as BCLC stage B and C patients were also
represented. And features typically associated with high risk of recurrence in
HCC, including elevated AFP at baseline, large lesion diameter,
macrovascular invasion, and multifocal disease were also represented in this
cohort.
In this trial, 15 patients were ultimately randomized and received treatment
in each study arm. And in both arms, the trial met its primary endpoint
as no patients experienced any treatment-related adverse events that precluded
surgery. In the nivolumab arm, three of 15 patients or 20% had
a complete pathologic or major
pathologic response. And in the combination arm, four of 15 patients or
26.7% had a pathologic or radiographic complete or
major response.
On the left here is a waterfall plot for RECIST from baseline to the
two-month time point where patients were evaluated for surgery.
And we can see in arm A, in the nivolumab arm, there was an objective response
rate of 13.3% compared to 20% in the combination arm.
There was one case of pseudo progression shown here, denoted by the letter P, as
well as one complete radiographic response in the combination arm denoted by the
letter C.
On the right-hand side, here is a spider plot of patients who have elevated AFP at
baseline, showing the dynamics of AFP from baseline to surgical
evaluation. And of note of patients who received surgery and had
decreasing AFP, none of the patients have recurred thus far on
trial.
And here's a case study of the complete responder to neoadjuvant nivo plus
rela. This patient deferred completion surgery after experiencing a complete
radiographic response, which can be seen in the first two images.
However, several years later in 2024, the tumor recurred in the same segment six
of the liver, as shown here on the right-hand image.
And to us, this kind of suggests that neoadjuvant ICIs may not actually be fully
ablative in the setting of a complete radiographic response.
In addition, salvage local ablation therapy was performed now, and the patient
remains recurrence-free to this day.
In terms of survival data, on the left-hand side here is disease-free survival, and
patients who never achieved disease-free status or experienced disease-free status,
excuse me,
were excluded from this analysis.
And in arm A, shown here on the left in blue, the one-year
DFS and the two-year DFS were all 73.3%.
In arm B, the one-year DFS was 100%, and the two-year DFS was
88.9%. On the right-hand side here is the overall survival
curve. In red is shown as arm B. There was a one-year
OS of 93.3% and a two-year OS of 84.8%.
And in arm A shown in blue, there was a one-year
OS of 86.2% and a two-year OS of 68.5%.
The median follow-up here was 26.3 months, and median overall survival
was not achieved in either study arm.
For an exploratory analysis for survival stratified by pathologic
response status, pathologic responders on this trial have not
had an event thus far on trial, and this result
approaches statistical significance despite minimal study numbers.
In terms of adverse events and safety, there were no grade five toxicities on this
trial, and in both arms, four of 15 patients had grade three
treatment-related adverse events or greater.
In terms of immune-related adverse events, in arm A, 46.7% of
patients had an IRE, and in arm B, that was compared to
73.3%. Consistent with historic reports of
combination ICIs having greater incidence of IREs.
This result was numerically but not statistically greater.
And in both arms, there was one unacceptable grade three IRE.
Here's an exploratory analysis of LAG-3 receptor occupancy.
And at time of surgery, in both CD4 and CD8 T cells,
the LAG-3 receptor occupancy was markedly lower in the tumor-infiltrating
lymphocytes compared to the peripheral blood
lymphocytes. And investigating further on the right-hand side,
we see a moderate negative inverse correlation despite limited sample size
of 10 samples in arm B of the study
between the largest lesion diameter as well as CD4 LAG-3 receptor
occupancy, suggesting to us that there's a size dependence under-penetration of
tumor at 480 milligrams of relatimab.
And for preliminary TME analysis, which is currently ongoing as well,
pathologic responders defined as complete or major pathologic responders have
increased tumoral CD45, CD3 density, as well as
TLS B-cell and B-cell chemoattractant CXCL13 density that
was greater than in non-pathologic responders.
And so in summary, this trial establishes nivolumab and nivolumab
plus relatimab as safe and feasible perioperative therapies in
patients with potentially resectable HCC.
We find that LAG-3 receptor occupancy is markedly lower in the HCC
TME than in the periphery for patients dosed at 480 milligrams of
relatimab.
Pathologic responders to neoadjuvant nivolumab or the combination
therapy have favorable survival outcomes and have significantly greater T cell,
B-cell, and TLS density than non-responders, and ongoing work to characterize the
TME as well as ctDNA dynamics is currently
ongoing.We would like to thank the patients,
families, and caretakers that were involved in this study, as well as the AACR
organizers and session chairs for their time.
And I would like to thank my primary mentor, Mark Yarchoan, for his mentorship, as
well as other members of the Yarchoan Lab, as well as other
collaborators at Hopkins and Ohio State.
And thank you to our funding partners, Bristol Myers Squibb, for making this trial
possible. I welcome any questions. Thank you.
Okay. Well, that was an outstanding presentation, Mr. Howard Lee.
Thank you.
I guess I inadvertently gave you a pre-presentation promotion
and gave you your degree already, in reference to you as doctor.
But questions for
Howard?
So the
receptor occupancy, we usually dose
these drugs based on blood level-
Mm-hmm
... but the receptor occupancy of the peripheral
lymphocytes relative to the tumor is markedly
different.
Mm-hmm.
So does this suggest that
dosing ought to be based on receptor occupancy within the tumor for
HCC, or maybe another delivery mode, like
intra-arterial or something like that?
Yeah. It's a good question, and I think the study actually started at a higher
dosage and was decreased to 400 milligrams after safety concerns of
hypokinetis and myositis in some of the other relatlimab trials.
And so it is a good question. I think the receptor occupancy in the periphery at
400 milligrams was near 100%. And so perhaps,
it is something that is just
a nature of HCC tumors being large and having high
hydrostatic pressure that limits penetration for some of these tumors.
But with other drugs, the ADCs, I think you don't need that
much drug to get to the actual tumor itself to have an effect.
However, I think some dose optimization studies could be explored here, as
well as potentially a triplet therapy to allow for maybe vascular normalization for
a highly vascular therapy with something like anti-VEGF as a
triplet combination as well could be explored.
Well, it's a bit of a nuisance, but intra-arterial therapy would probably also
achieve higher-
Mm-hmm
... intra-tumoral drug levels specifically for HCC.
That makes sense.
Okay, a question I had, a thought that came to mind.
These are large tumors that were in your study.
Mm-hmm.
And you mentioned that ablative therapy was usually given more
as salvage instead of upfront. But
radiating intact tumors
in combination with
immune checkpoint inhibitors in other solid tumor types has been
shown to improve the tumor microenvironment by
recruiting more tumor-infiltrating lymphocytes.
Mm-hmm.
And even if you don't give the full ablative dose to the
entire large hepatocellular cancer, it might be a
thought to maybe radiate just part of it to
immunostimulate the microenvironment, and then help,
even if the concentration of the relatimib was low, maybe
improve the efficacy of how that response is happening.
I see. Thank you. And I would note that the responders to therapy did not
have elevated LAG-3 RO in the tumor-
Yeah
... compared to non-responders as well.
So if it really matters, it was a very small preliminary analysis of
probably less than 10 patients.
But whether or not it really matters also remains to be a question.
Sure. Well, you did an excellent job.
There's a question on the left.
Oh, sorry.
Yes.
I
wanted you to comment, if you can, in terms of the discrepancies that
you saw with the response by RECIST
versus the pathologic response-
Mm-hmm
... that you saw. I think in the abstract, there were some differences.
So she wanted to know the differences between the RECIST
versus the pathologic response.
Yeah.
I think, yeah, there probably were some differences.
I don't know if you mean by a typo in the
abstract. But in terms of why they may be a little bit different here, I
think the RECIST response was done at two months,
and sometimes I think the pathologic response and the RECIST response
don't necessarily correlate as what's going on in the tumor may not be captured by
radiographic scans yet. And I think perhaps some of the discrepancies
there may be due to that. However, I can double-check
if you are referring to something else.
Thank you.
Okay. Is there anyone else out there? Thank you.
Okay. I don't see anyone, so we're going to move on.
And if we could have our last speaker, Dr.
McCann from Memorial Sloan Kettering
Cancer Center. Here he is.
And he will be speaking on
Neoadjuvant IL-1β and PD-1
Inhibition in Localized Clear Cell Renal Cell Carcinoma: Clinical and
Correlative Analyses of the Phase 1B
SPARK-1 Trial.
Hi, everyone. My name is Patrick McCann.
I'm a research project associate at Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer Center.
And today, it's my pleasure to present the clinical and correlative analysis of the
SPARK-1 trial, which tested the neoadjuvant inhibition of
IL-1β and PD-1 in localized clear cell renal cell carcinoma.
I have no financial disclosures.
Clear cell renal cell carcinomas are highly immunogenic and are characterized
by high and abundant T-cell
and myeloid infiltrate.
However, these suppressive myeloid cells can also drive resistance in a
specific subset of macrophages. The C1Q Trem2-positive
macrophages correlate with overall poorer outcome.
The standard of care for renal cell carcinomas remains nephrectomy.
However, patients with high-risk disease still present with a 20% to
30% chance of recurrence.Although
immunotherapies are approved in the adjuvant setting, such as
anti-PD-1 and more recently, anti-PD-1 plus
HIF-2 alpha inhibitors, there's no current role for
neoadjuvant therapy.
Preclinical models have shown in the
preclinical murine RENCA model, combination treatment with
PD-1 and IL-1 beta, one, improved tumor control, and
two,
shifted the macrophages toward a more M1-like
phenotype,
suggesting that it is more anti-tumor.
To combat the suppressive TAM-rich TME, we hypothesize
that the addition of canakinumab, which is an anti-IL-1 beta
monoclonal antibody with a combination of spartalisumab
anti-PD-1,
will target the suppressive myeloid signaling and T cell dysfunction
and lead to a less suppressive myeloid program.
The key inclusion of the SPARK-1 study was radiographic or
histologically confirmed clear cell renal cell carcinoma for patients with
stages T1b to T4 disease.
N1 disease was allowed.
Spartalisumab and canakinumab were given twice, four weeks apart,
six weeks prior to nephrectomy,
and followed for 12 months. The primary endpoint of this study
was the safety and feasibility of these agents, and their
exploratory endpoints was 12 months metastasis-free survival, as
well as characterizing immune response through single-cell RNA sequencing and
high parametric flow cytometry.
Here are the baseline patient characteristics.
There were 14 patients enrolled on this trial, with ages ranging from
33 to 81,
with 64.3% of patients presenting with local
disease.
The combination treatment of anti-IL-1 beta and
anti-PD-1 was well-tolerated.
50% of patients had exhibited a treatment-related adverse
event, and there were no Grade 3 or 4 treatment-related adverse
events.
All patients proceeded to surgery without unexpected complications.
Notably, this was a high-risk population with 64.3% of
patients having T3 disease and 56%
having nuclear Grades 3 or 4.
When using the ASSURE nomogram to predict overall recurrence for these
patients,
57.1% were predicted to have early
disease progression, which is defined as a metastasis
within 12 months.
Over one year, no patients had recurred.
At extended follow-up, there was one recurrence at three and a half years,
and when we overlaid the ASSURE predicted disease-free
survival,
there was a 38.7% improvement in disease-free survival
compared to the predicted at six years.
At time of nephrectomy, we profiled these tumors for
single-cell RNA sequencing and flow cytometry.
In addition to the trial cohort, we collected a cohort of untreated
samples.
For single-cell RNA sequencing, we did a CD45
enrichment and sequenced both the CD45-enriched and the
non-immune component.
We further inferred protein activity with the VIPER
algorithm and clustered downstream.
For flow cytometry,
we split the sample up into two panels, the myeloid panel and the
T cell panel,
and batch corrected using the CyTOVI algorithm and further clustered downstream.
Here's the myeloid clustering by flow cytometry.
We identified three monocyte populations, a neutrophil
population, dendritic cells, and three
tumor-associated macrophage populations.
Here are some density maps split by treatment.
First, we saw a significant decrease in neutrophils, which is
consistent with the mechanism of action of IL-1 beta and has also
been shown to be immunosuppressive in the tumor microenvironment.
Additionally, we saw an increase in CD206
TAMs.
CD206 has been canonically defined as an M2-like marker.
However, they've been more recently linked to a
CXCL9 high anti-tumor TAM phenotype.
To further characterize these macrophage subclusters, we
looked at our single-cell RNA sequencing and identified two TAM
populations: SPP1-positive TAMs and
CXCL9-positive TAMs.
The CXCL9-positive TAMs exhibited more of an M1-like
phenotype, and the SPP1-positive TAMs were more
M2-like.
Characterizing the ratio between these two clusters, we saw a
significant increase in the CXCL9 TAM to SPP1 TAM
ratio with the combination treatment of IL-1 beta and
anti-PD-1.
Further, looking into the expression of IL-1 beta, we saw a
decrease in the treatment group,
suggesting
the mechanism of action of IL-1 beta is working.
And we also saw increased CXCL9 expression,
suggesting that we shifted these TAMs toward a more
anti-tumor-like state.
Overlaying these single-cell RNA sequencing gene signatures, the
SPP1 TAMswere poorly prognostic,
and the CXCL9 TAMs correlated with overall better prognosis.
Looking into our T cells,
we saw a trend towards an increase in the CD8 T cell compartment,
and to further characterize these T cells, we sub-clustered them, identifying
seven sub-phenotypes.
First, we saw a significant increase in the naive
CD8 T cells, suggesting enhanced CD8 T cell infiltration.
And we also saw a significant increase in progenitor
exhausted one T cells, suggesting an expanded progenitor
pool capable of sustaining anti-tumor responses.
In conclusion, anti-IL1 beta and anti-PD-1 is safe and feasible.
It was well-tolerated with no Grade 3 or 4 adverse events, and
100% of patients proceeded to surgery.
It also reveals promising clinical activity with
100% of patients achieving metastasis-free
survival at 12 months.
And there's also evidence of remodeling.
One, evidence of macrophage repolarization towards the anti-tumor
phenotype, and two, an increased CD8 T cell infiltrate.
First, I would like to thank the patients and their support network.
And next, I would like to thank the collaborators at MSK,
Mayo, and Columbia University.
Thank you.
Thanks, Sam. So, someone on the left there.
Nice presentation. How do you distinguish the effect of IL1 beta
versus PD-1 in this, the changes you're seeing?
Because some of the TAMs could be the effect of T cell
changes made with the PD-1 that is having, how do you distinguish the effect?
Yeah. So we kind of can't. So since
both
of these regimens were given together,
that's one limitation of this is that we can't tease out what the IL1 beta's
doing versus what the PD-1 is doing.
I think there's maybe a small cohort of patients that may have received
PD-1 prior to nephrectomy off-label, but
we'd have to further investigate these cases to see if we can tease out the effects
of the PD-1 versus the IL1 beta.
So in your concluding slide, you pointed out
reprogramming the myeloid niche and
so when you're treating inside with the tumor in place in
this neoadjuvant window, that works.
I guess the question is:
Is that needed in the adjuvant setting?
Is the myeloid niche still going to be immunosuppressive, or do you think
is the deal that the
expansion of the T cells has
been achieved and
you don't need to reprogram the myeloid niche in the post-resection adjuvant
setting?
Yeah. I think given the biology of the renal cell
TME, it is definitely myeloid-rich.
And I think directly targeting the myeloid-rich versus
whether when these patients may have
micrometastatic disease somewhere else, I think it may be better in the
neoadjuvant setting, but it is interesting that we could also look
into the adjuvant setting. It may also
improve survival in metastasis-free events.
To the left.
Hi, I'm Ayesha Hassan from Johnson & Johnson.
Really interesting data and very fascinating for this pathway.
There were lung cancer trials done early on where, at least in
the adjuvant setting, canakinumab didn't demonstrate the activity, which
is disappointing.
Have you looked at, just from the clinical perspective,
did these patients that came in have higher CRP
levels? Did you follow those CRP levels
post-treatment, and was that in any way correlated?
Yes. So CRP was built into the protocol.
However, I would have to double-check exactly on those lab values.
Good question.
Thank you.
Okay. Super. Thank you.
So with my hat on, I want to take a few minutes to
pull together the presentations.
If you could put up my slides here. So these excellent presentations we've heard
today endorse several paradigms
about the neoadjuvant therapy window.
Oh, I guess I do it myself. I'm sorry.
The data confirmed that we're moving towards a view of the neoadjuvant
window truly as a multifaceted opportunity.
There is the potential for surgical de-escalation and organ preservation,
and as a surgeon, that's certainly meaningful,
as well as to the patients, obviously.
In the HER2-amplified rectal cancer study, we see that finding the right drug
for the right molecular subset has incredible potential.
By identifying the specific HER2 population and matching it with the
targeted therapy, it provides a
opportunity for less surgery that results in organ preservation and
possibly even a watch-and-wait pathway that avoids surgery
completely. But even though I talk about
organ preservation and de-escalation of surgery,
one shouldn't think that using the neoadjuvant window is simply about
shrinkage before surgery. It's about systemic immune priming
and microenvironment programming that we just saw in the last two presentations
in HCC and renal cell
carcinoma.And lastly, the neoadjuvant window serves
as a biological stress test. And so throughout all these presentations, we
saw that we're getting real-time readout of how a specific tumor
biology responds to a specific targeted intervention.
And readouts like ctDNA can provide very,
very significant prognostic consequences.
And so this leads to integration of
anatomic and biologic staging. You know, For all of
us, AJCC staging remains the foundation and language of
staging, but we're now refining that
bedrock through a hierarchy of predictive factors.
The CheckMate 77t data that we saw shows that dynamic markers,
the ctDNA clearance, and pathologic response emerge
as the most powerful predictors of long-term survival.
But you may recall that TNM still was relevant in
that particular analysis because in that study, N status or
specifically non N2 node involvement remained
a critical prognostic factor. And so this is a hybrid
staging system, and we see that information also lies in molecular
resolution, where we saw that integrating target density into
staging, such as the HER2 copy number,
there's movement away from the one size fits all guideline to deliver the
right drug to the right subset within the traditional
AJCC categories. And finally, we look towards the next
generation of guidelines. And actually, frankly, I shouldn't say next generation
because these are upon us already.
Response adapted protocols. Historically, we've relied on
fixed duration, but now there are opportunities for personalized
protocols.
The results of the PRADO study in melanoma, which weren't discussed
here, but strongly suggest that we can deescalate surgery and deescalate
duration of adjuvant therapy
based on the depth of the pathologic response seen in the resected
specimen.
Data from today's presentation suggests that cure signatures are
emerging through pathCR, ctDNA clearance,
and favorable transcriptomics. Now, I put the word cure
in quotes, and actually, I used it deliberately, frankly, because actually
this session used in its title the word cure, but we
don't throw that term around loosely. It's a pretty bold term.
But the point is that there are markers that identify
patients with the highest probability of long-term
remission. So they provide a roadmap for strategic
de-escalation that allows us to escalate for persistent
molecular disease and safely explore an exit ramp for those patients
whose biology has already achieved a complete reset and probably don't need,
for example, 13 cycles of adjuvant immunotherapy
outback.
So in summary, we use the neoadjuvant window to probe the
biology and obtain dynamic molecular staging to
anchor treatment decisions. Within molecular clearance,
there is the potential for de-escalation of surgery and de-escalation of
adjuvant therapy, as well as escalation of adjuvant
therapy when necessary. And then I'd like to give a plug for
another neoadjuvant tailored therapy clinical trial that's about to
launch, namely the AACR Adaptive Biomarker Driven Organ
Preservation Trial in Gastroesophageal Adenocarcinomas.
The schema is shown here, and for those of you with interest and questions,
it's being presented Tuesday morning in poster
2233.
So those are my comments. Thank you.
This concludes this mini symposium, and on behalf of the AACR
and my co-chair, Dr. Alice Ho, I'd like to thank you for your
participation.